[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unique kay
willkommen zurück persönlichen bessere
so willkommen zurück happy halloween das
ist das so eine katze ist ein übrigens
die katze rechts die katze menge service
ich bin übrigens dass gewisse keine
tiere sind aber fast meinen lebewesen
mit gesicht
heute werden wir einen berühmten und für
uns sehr wichtig denke besprechen
nämlich alles dort ließ bekannt mit der
schule platons der wahrscheinlich der
wichtigste philosoph ist für mindestens
für die geschichte der philosophie in
der europäischen tradition
das ist nicht wunderlich denn er der
wichtigste philosoph in der europäischen
geschichte schlechthin ist alles lesen
war für 2000 jahre fasst die der
philosoph der den man immer als leben
als den attraktivsten denker der antike
genommen hat und in der spätantike und
mittelalter in der songs war er fast
sein name war fast synonym mit
philosophie wenn man zum beispiel in
antiken spätantiken alexandria in
ägypten oder in paris und 19 jahrhundert
oder im park dem zehnten jahrhundert
wenn man flüssig wie studieren wollte
hat man mit aristoteles angefangen bzw
war war oft der ganze lehrgang in
philosophie ausschließlich
aristotelische bücher
eine logik seine physik oder ist eine
naturphilosophie seine ethik seine mathe
physik für das vieh war einfach
aristotelische philosophie von daher
werden wir in den kommenden wochen sehen
wir werden in die durch das ganze
semester sehen das alles sollte ließ der
die hauptquelle für spätere philosophen
wenn es um tiere philosophie geht er ist
oft die hauptquelle oder eine
hauptquelle natürlich nicht in
klassischen indien oder in afrika was
bei aufgespalten werden
aber in der europäischen tradition steht
da das wirklich sehr oft im mittelpunkt
und dazu kann man auch sagen dass lotte
leases ideen sortieren auch für uns
immer noch heute relevant sind zum
beispiel es ist in der thier
wissenschaften der jetzigen zoologie
gängig dass man tiere oder würden seinem
tierarten einordnet wir haben ich weiß
nicht wie das genau funktioniert aber
ganz oben haben wir familien oder
irgendwo essen wir haben gattin und alt
und so weiter und diese dieses ganze
system was man heute gymnasium in
biologie lernens das kommt nicht bei des
ortes vor
aber die grundsätzliche idee kommt schon
bei ihm vor das heißt für die erhöhte
sagen okay katze ist in der gattung tier
oder lebewesen zorn und dann ist die art
katz
das ist dann eine gliederung einer
größeren garten und das gilt für alle
nicht nur für tiere hatten sondern für
alle arten zum beispiel ist stein auch
eine art und das ist unter einer anderen
gattung geordnet zum beispiel mehrere
hallen oder
oder vielleicht nicht stein aber
irgendwas bestimmtes zum beispiel marmor
ist eine art unter der gattung stein
stein ist eine weitere art unter einer
höheren garten mit mineralien und so
weiter und das kommt schon in seinen
logischen werken vor
diese idee dass man universelle
gattungen und arten in einer art von
baum die das auch später in der
geschichte so wie oft dargestellt wurde
vor allem anhand des werks 1 1 stellen
den wir später in vancouvers das heißt
oft der baum von pro für ios die idee
dass man die arten und gattungen in
einer in einem also beim für einweg
darstellen kann
das kommt so eine inhalte sollte diese
logische werke vor
allerdings haben wir schon eine finte
man sagen eine vorahnung davon bei
platon vor allem in dem service des und
in dem politik als das sind zwei
dialogen die sehr eng miteinander
verwandt sind weil die also die idee es
dass die gleiche also sei eigentlich ein
gespräch wo die gleiche personen im
dialog zuerst definieren was der so fest
ist und dann was wäre der politikers ist
oder was ist denn was ist ein politiker
oder staatsmann und theoretisch wollten
sie dann danach besprechen was ein
philosoph ist es gibt aber keinen dialog
namens wieder so auf jeden fall der
hauptfigur in diesen zwei dialogen ein
sogenannter fremder aus ler in italien
irgendwas mit paris zu tun weil er es
irgendwie ein fiktiver nachfolger vom
paradies er hat eine philosophische
methode wo er vorschlägt dass wenn man
einen begriff verstehen
soll man das unter einem so man diesen
begriff unter einer großen größeren
gattung einordnen zum beispiel wenn man
verstehen will was ein fischer ist soll
man das und jäger dann einordnen und
dann einfach sagen welche art von jäger
ist das ähnlicher weise könnte man sich
vorstellen wenn wir verstehen wollen was
katze ist sind wir ganz oben anfangen
zum beispiel den oder vielleicht nicht
denken dass so allgemein aber lebewesen
und dann pflanzen tiere hier nichts
pflanze als säugetiere oder vielleicht
vierbeiniges tier nicht zwei gängige ist
hier
diese dieses beispiel kommt oft bei in
der platonischen tradition vor und so
weiter und so fort was man nur also
sozusagen nur die katzen isoliert hat
unterhalb dieser größeren garten von
lebewesen und vielleicht würde man
dadurch sogar eine liste von den
wesentlichen eigenschaften erreichen die
den katzen gehören zum beispiel wenn man
sagt wir haben ein lebewesen und das
lesen hat für beine ist fleischfresser
ist reisen gehen macht weil wasser also
die eigenschaften die man benutzt und
die katzen in diesem baum zu isolieren
werden dann wenn uns dann die notwendige
und ausreichende bedingungen geben um
katze zu bestimmen also die idee wie
gesagt stammt aus plattform ist aber bei
hat es dort liest sehr wichtig und sehr
präsent
und das heißt dass bei aller dort lesen
der späteren an der station tradition
ist
ist so sein unsere idee dass man tiere
als tierarten versteht oder dass man die
tierarten so voneinander unterscheidet
das ist schon ein alter gedanke der
zurück zuerst wie es geht
apropos als sind für alle sorten ist die
tierarten sehr bald sogar ewig das heißt
die tiere die wir jetzt als total ist
natürlich mit einzelne katzen oder
giraffen aber die tierarten die wir
heutzutage erleben können sind genau die
tiere hatten die schon immer existiert
haben und die immer existieren werden in
der zukunft wenig training gibt es kein
phänomen wie aussterben eine tierart es
gibt auch keine evolution
das ist nicht und vielleicht denkt man
sofort ja natürlich nicht weil es ist so
lange her
darin kommt erst tausende jahre später
keine wunder dass er nicht drangekommen
ist aber dass nichts zu vergessen
wir hatten schon einen denker der eine
art evolutionstheorie hatte nämlich
empedokles in petto drews und er war
nicht der einzige aber es gab sogar
mörder der vorzug artikel der anschein
der ansicht waren dass wir halten durch
irgend ein natürliches prozesses
entstehen nachdem sie noch nicht
existiert hatten in paris hat die
ausführlichste version einer solchen
terry soweit wir wissen wie wir heute
sehen werden kritisiert dass diese
theorie das ist bewusst dass man der
meinung sein könnte das tier hatten
entstehen nachdem sie noch nicht
existieren
das will er aber nicht haben was er
haben will ist dass die tiere halten
ewig sind und übrigens nicht
nur tierarten sondern alle arten zum
beispiel in marburg wäre auch ein
wenn das wirklich eine natürliche art
ist dann hat es schon immer marmor
gegeben es wird auch immer für immer
machen wir geben mensch natürlich
es hat immer und man kann sogar sagen
dass das ganze universum war immer so
gestaltet wie jetzt in planet erde in
der mitte mit das ist aus luft feuer
erde wasser und dann himmels werden um
der erde in konzentrischen 2 wieso denkt
ihr das aus mehreren gründen ein grund
wäre vielleicht die frage wenn wir zum
beispiel keine katzen hätten wo er
würden wir kratzen wollen wie wir können
karten entstehen wo es keine katzen
bisher gibt und das werde für alle
sorten dieses sehr schwierig zu erkennen
vielleicht sogar unmöglich zu erklären
weil er der ansicht ist dass die form
einer katze immer von einer früheren
katze kommen muss es gibt diese berühmte
frage was kommt zuerst huhn oder ei
antwort keine sorge nichts kommt zuerst
es gab schon himmel hühner und eier und
jeder hund kommt von einem anderen hund
aus einer also hohen bremer ähnlicher
weise kommt jede katze von einer mutter
katze und von einem papa katze
und die form der katze wird von diesen
eltern wie er später sein werden war
vorwiegend durch den papa katze denn für
den kater wir die form vorwiegend
weitergeliefert an das baby kätzchen das
war doch so gut dass ich so eine süße so
ein süßes beispiel ausgesucht haben
sollte das ein grund also wenn man so
sagen in einer katzen losen welt
anfangen würde will man keinen keinen
mitteln haben katzen zu produzieren
deswegen können sie nie entstehen aber
es gibt auch eine vielleicht eine tiefe
der begründung dafür oder für mindestens
folgten motivation und das hat mit einem
anderen werk zu tun was man was wir
normalerweise nicht mit hirn oder
synergie verbinden würden nämlich die
analytiker postierte oder das ist ein
logisches werk mindestens in der
tradition würde das als logisches werk
eingestuft hatte ließ seine technologie
vorstellt nicht unbedingt eine
allgemeine theorie der kosmologie wie
wir uns das vorstellen würden aber
mindestens eine theorie die systeme
entsteht also systeme heißt natürlich
wissen oder wissenschaft auf
altgriechisch
und daher haben wir was das wort pistole
logi und also die frage in diesem werk
das sind die zentrale frage nicht die
einzige frage eine frage ist was ist das
thema was ist wissen oder wissenschaft
und woher wollt oder wie wie entsteht
wissen sie wie kommen wir zu wissen
nachdem wir das noch nicht haben
und da könnte man sehr vieles dazu sagen
ich könnte natürlich eine vorlesung dazu
halten aber zu kurz kurze fassung ist
das system für al assad ließ nur
natürlich nur mit wahrheiten zu tun hat
also wenn ich irgendwas weiß dann muss
ich das was ich weiß muss natürlich war
es seien also kann nicht wissen dass
zwei plus zwei gleich fünf fest es
müssten wahr sein das ist ja wie klar
das würde jeder zu stellen
aber das reicht natürlich nicht ich
könnte zum beispiel auch eine wahre
meinung haben
das wäre aber nicht wissen zum beispiel
vielleicht sage ich dass trotz neuer
erfahrungen wird rc bayern das deutsche
die deutsche pokal gewinnen
ja ok und das ist meine meinung aber
natürlich weiß es weil sich das doch
nichts und wenn ich behaupten würde dass
ich das schon weiß können sie mit recht
sagen dass das wissen sie nichts
höchstens haben sie recht aber sie
meinen es nur das ist eine vermutung
vielleicht ist sogar eine wahre meinung
oder weil ware vermutung das heißt am
ende werden sie den pokal holen aber
trotzdem ist das nicht wissen
das ist zwar der meinung und wissen
deren beide mit wahrheiten unschön sind
aber unterschiedlich
das zeigt uns dass es das andere
bedingungen erfüllt werden müssen damit
wissen entsteht nicht nur dass wir eine
wahre überzeugung haben sondern dass die
überzeugung andere qualitäten oder
eigenschaften besitzt und hat es hat
eine sehr ambitionierte reihe von
bedingungen die erfüllt werden müssen
unter anderem muss die muster systeme
begründet sein dass wir in der regel
wird das schott so ausschauen systeme
wir haben prämisse eines arguments 1
lukas muss also sikhismus die als
schluss unsere systeme also die die
überzeugung anschluss ergeben
und diese prämissen und auch der schluss
müssen weiterhin andere bedingungen
erfüllen also herzens müssen natürlich
erklären oder begründen warum der
schluss richtig ist natürlich muss das
argument auch schlüssig sein also von
der form her muss das argument richtig
sein muss stimmen
aber auch und jetzt kommen wir zurück
zum thema die christen müssten nicht nur
wasser sie müssen sicher wahr sein
also wir müssen sicherheit haben dass
diese prämisse stimmen sonst könnten wir
nicht wissen dass die schlussfolgerung
zu einer sicheren wahrheit führt zum
beispiel vielleicht habe ich habe ich
keine begründung warum fc bayern dieses
pokal diese pop ist die pokale der dass
das war die einzige möglichkeit die ich
nichts den pokal
also vielleicht habe ich eine begründung
warum fc bayern den pokal holen werde
und dann sage ich ja die haben
lewandowski er ist der beste stürmer
jetzt ist dort letzten gestern abend hat
gladbach verloren oder gladbach ist
schon weg und dortmund wird auch weg
sein begründet
also ich hab eine argument zu sagen und
das ist schon irgendwie eine begründung
aber ich berufe auf prämisse die auch
nicht sicherlich war sein zb bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass dort man irgendwann
verliert und dann sind sie am ende nicht
mehr drin und dann muss bayern nichts
dortmund besiegen
aber das weiß ich auch nicht wenn ich
sicherheit über diesen schluss habe muss
ich mich auf prämisse berufen die auch
sicherlich war sind das sicherheits
etwas anderes zu sagen ich muss bei den
primaten ausschließen können dass die
prämisse vielleicht falsch sind
es reicht nicht dass die prämisse war
sind es muss auch der fall sein dass die
presse nichts falsch sein können
was bedeutet es wenn wir verlangen dass
diese prämissen sicherlich bald sind war
alles so wie es heißt das dass die
prämisse notwendig war sind
und natürlich kann man sofort sehen wenn
a und b notwendigerweise wahr sind und
wenn die schlussfolgerung richtig ist
also die die form des argumentes stimmen
dann ist sich ist der schluss auch
notwendig war
anders gesagt ist erschlossen nur so
stark wie die prämisse das heißt wenn
die prämissen möglicherweise falsch sind
denn ist der schluss möglicherweise
falsch auch wenn die kulissenbauer sind
zum beispiel wenn ich sage in meinem
haus gerade jetzt dass eine katze
katzen sind lebewesen
deswegen ist gibt es in meinem haus
jetzt eine ein lebewesen das ist ein
schlüssiges argument also die
schlussfolgerung ist richtig und es ist
sicherlich war notwendigerweise war dass
katzen lebewesen sind ist es aber nicht
notwendigerweise der fall dass es jetzt
eine katze in meinem haus sich befindet
ja ich hab sogar eine katze namens kappe
habe ich irgendwann erwähnt glaube ich
und pappe ist oft in dem haus aber oft
eben nichts sieht auf dem garten und
liebt das rein und da raus zu gehen
müssen sich ständig für einen rauslassen
weil wir keine katzen zu haben sind sie
dass sie macht so wir haben eine glastür
sie kommt zu der tür und macht so der
tür dann wenn wir sie reinlassen ja
deswegen haben wir etwas steifen an
natur ist auf jeden fall
ich kann ihnen im moment gerade nichts
sagen ob meine katze in dem haus ist
also vielleicht ist die ganze
schlussfolgerung nicht nur stimmlich
sondern auch war vielleicht gibt es eine
katze in dem haus hatten sind sicherlich
lebewesen und wenn das alles stimmt
können wir sagen dass ein lebewesen im
haus ist leider ist
wo uns im moment nicht bekannt ob die
erste prämisse war ist und das
auszuschließen will alter sorten ist
immer das also wenn es um systeme also
regelrecht es wissen geht will emma dass
die prämissen notwendigerweise wahr sind
und das heißt für ihn immer war
selbst wenn ich zu hause bin und ich
sage hier ist papa sie ich kann sie
sitzt vor mir es im haus selbst dann
könnt ihr das als prämisse nicht in
einer in einer das in einem
wissenschaftlichen zusammenhang könnte
diese prämissen nichts vorbringen in
einem juristischen argumente um wissen
zu erreichen weil sie obwohl ich sehen
kann
das papier in dem haus ist allein die
tatsache dass papa nicht immer im haus
ist das reicht um diese prämisse
auszuschließen kann ich darf nur
prämissen prämisse hernehmen die immer
war es sind dieses immer oder ewig diese
ewigkeit der wahrheit hängt für adessa
dies mit der notwendigkeit zusammen und
das erklärt dann warum es so ist es noch
ein grund warum es so wichtig ist das
tier hat ein ewig sind wenn wir hatten
mit ewig wenn können wir beständig keine
wissenschaft über tiere haben weil wir
würden keine ewig war ewige wahrheiten
zu tiere haben würden nur vorübergehende
beobachtungen oder wahrheiten haben die
für ihn nicht diese bedingung der
notwendigkeit erfüllen und das ist
übrigens sehr überraschend weil eben ein
aus unserer perspektive würde mir jetzt
sagen okay dann kann also solchen die es
eigentlich keine ware so logi haben nach
seiner technologischen voraussetzungen
und natürlich das hier halten nicht ewig
cent dialekt ihr hatten die existieren
haben nur seit ein paar jahren
vielleicht ein paar millionen jahren
existiert und das heißt es gibt keine
ewige die ewig war prämissen über tiere
könnte man trotzdem alles katholische
theologie retten
vielleicht nur wenn man die wahrheiten
über tiere kondition aloys legt zum
beispiel könnte man sagen wenn es auch
wenn auch immer ist ihre katzen gibt
sind katzen lebewesen oder wenn eine
katze ist dann ist es ein lebewesen so
aber das war nicht das war auch mit
aristoteles vorstellung wie diese
prämissen ausscheiden wollten so sollten
also er wollte immer das a und b und
subjekt und prädikat aus einem subjekt
und prädikat gebildet sind katzen sind
lebewesen zum beispiel also für alles
offen ließ wer es wirklich schwierig
anhand seiner wissenschaftstheorie wer
ist wirklich schwierig theologie als
wissenschaft zu bestehen wenn er nicht
voraussetzt dass lebewesen ewig cent und
übrigens das gilt für seine ganze
philosophie
also wird für ihn weil es um
wissenschaft geht so wie es immer so
ausschauen wie sollen wir dieses
logischen haben wird notwendig und
kontroversielle ewige wahrheiten als
prämisse und am schluss haben und nur
dann kann man sagen dass man
wissenschaftsszene erreicht hat
also dass eine ein deutlicher
unterschied zwischen seiner solo gi und
unserer sologesang allein die
vorstellung das tier hatten entstehen
würde für ihn das ganze projekt
irgendwie stürzen was natürlich für uns
etwas überraschend ist aber das sieht
man schon wie anders seine ganze
herangehensweise ist wie und das war
vielleicht ein bisschen kompliziert
vielleicht mag ich schon jetzt hause um
zu sehen ob jemand eine frage hat
verständnis frage weil das in berlin
klar
zusammen würde in der vergangenheit
nicht gar das funktioniert ja auch nicht
wenn es wieder zu ja ja ja er geht davon
aus dass das nicht stattfinden kann
jaja und eben einen hinten in seiner
welt war das irgendwie plausibel man die
idee dass menschen irgendwie schaffen
alle katzen umzubringen werde für ihn
offensichtlich unvorstellbar oder also
umweltverschmutzer ist also da solche
probleme ist dass er einfach nicht dran
gekommen
ja das ist eine gute frage
ja die zum beispiel also er hätte wissen
sollen dass man zum beispiel werde
mischen kann also ein braunes pferd ein
weißes werden dann hat man ein paar
braune und weiße einfällt was bei
hinweise
gute frage
da würde er zurück zu dieser theorie mit
den piraten gehen müssen also er würde
sagen dass innerhalb einer tier hat dass
man immer was die das heißt bei ihm
aktienanteile eigenschaften man kann
immer aktie den teller eigenschaften
haben die die mitglieder einer stewart
unterscheidet oder unterscheiden zum
beispiel sie haben habe ich nicht dass
es uns axi dental als menschen also als
mensch kann man karl sein oder hart wie
sie jetzt nennen würde
wegen des stiftes ein sehr schönes wort
hält das heißt dass man bill hare hat es
gibt sieben nicht sieht und die und die
eigenschaften die uns gehör als menschen
gehören sind nicht akzente sondern
wesentlich zum beispiel wissen beide
nationen nationale lebewesen uhren oder
wir sind beide wahrzunehmen solche
sachen also die es gibt eigenschaften
die uns als menschen gehören und dann
andere eigenschaften die uns als
einzelne einzelne menschen gehören
ich glaube was er dann sagen müsste ist
das zum beispiel wenn man zwei pferde
braun und weiß und dann hat man ein
gepunktetes wert als resultat der würde
sagen ja klar weil es gehört nicht zu
dem pferd braun zu sein oder weiß zu
sein
aber dass man zwei arten zum ersten mal
partie und eine ganz neue art davon oder
davon entsteht das würde ausschließen
müssen offiziellen mindestens
wir brauchen diese frage kommen
ja ja interessant ja dass dieses
beispiel nennt er sogar wenn er sagt man
sieht dass das nicht natürlich ist weil
sie keine kinder verbringen können und
deswegen ist das keine art das ist nur
eine 1 1 praktisch 1 gegen natürliches
wesen
man sieht dass das keine art ist da
genau daran dass diese dieses tier kann
keine weitere solche tiere vor bringen
das ist wegen 1 also dieses beispiel für
ihn ist ein beweis der theorie richtig
ist ich weiß dass seine theorie nicht
richtig ist trotzdem okay so das bringt
uns seine solo gi und hier muss man
wirklich sagen also werden werden heute
ein paar thesen weil das wirken dieses
besprechen die für uns hier
offensichtlich falsch sind oder
mindestens falsch wenn die hafencity
falsch und wir werden sogar ein paar
ideen über geschlecht sehen die wir
wahrscheinlich nicht mögen werden
trotzdem bin ich der meinung dass wenn
es und ihr wissenschaft und philosophie
geht alles so wie es ist wirklich er ist
ein regelrechtes hält in der geschichte
der team philosophie und tier
wissenschaft denn er der erste war der
wirklich wissenschaftlich untersucht hat
und beobachtet hat vor allem hat er
erstaunlich viel seite mühe gegeben um
die tiere zu beobachten und sogar so
zieren zum beispiel muscheln fische also
alles was im wasser lebt es gibt
geschichten über ihn dass er in der nähe
von einem see gewohnt hat und dass er
plötzlich alle alle die die tiere aus
dem wasser geholt hat oder was
wahrscheinlich hat man ihm die fische
gebracht wenn er hat sie zitiert und
dann beschreibt er die das was er
gesehen hat in seinen werken nicht nur
fische auch alle tierarten die den
griechen bekannt waren vielleicht nicht
alle aber sehr viele werden in seinen so
logischen werken besprochen
es ist wirklich erstaunlich und er es
gibt sogar eine sehr schöne passagen wo
er uns erklärt warum das interessant ist
und er sagt dass manche vielleicht
denken würden dass diese tiere hatten
diese mühe nicht wert sind weil sie so
bescheiden und sogar ein mies sind im
vergleich zum beispiel zu den himmels
werden hier denkt er wahrscheinlich an
kollegen von ihm und von platon in der
platonischen akademie die sich mit
astronomie beschäftigt hat und er gibt
zwar zu dass die himmels wenn das die
himmelskörper vielen noble sind und
erhabener als die tiere die er zitiert
aber dann sagte er ja klar aber die
himmelskörper sind weit weg und schwer
zu untersuchen werden die tiere hier
unter uns sind und leicht zu untersuchen
sind und die ganze natur ist für uns
interessant
also wenn wir studenten der natur sind
wenn wir naturphilosophie machen wollen
sondern wir auf keinen fall die tiere
außer acht lassen vor allem weil die
tiere sind die sind das leichteste zu
untersuchen die wir haben und wie gesagt
deswegen hat er all diese anatomische
forschung gemacht wie ihr seid wirklich
ein
also erstens ist es erstaunlich dass er
so für dieses projekt so ernsthaft
unternommen hat waren weil es gibt es
gibt halt vorgänger für diese
hinterlassen hatte wir haben gesehen
dass bei den vorsorge können dass sie ab
und zu irgend welche eigenschaften von
tieren besprochen haben aber sobald wir
wissen gab es keine ernsthafte versuche
tiere zum beispiel so zitieren
in der vorherigen flüssig wie also
erstens ist das beeindruckend dass er
die dieses projekt irgendwie zum ersten
mal konzipiert und dann soweit macht
also er hat sehr würde wirklich eine
wichtige rolle in die geschichte der
wissenschaft verdienen wenn wir nur
seine so logische werke hätten also
erstens das aber zweitens was vielleicht
irgendwie noch erstaunlich ist ist das
an seinen nachfolger dieses projekt
nicht weiter gebracht haben
der also für in der zoologie nach alter
sitte ries für vielleicht eineinhalb tal
sind ja tausend jahre war
so sank der bestand der wissenschaft war
eigentlich was hat das dort ließ gesagt
ein bisschen übertrieben wie wir auch
nächste woche sehen werden gab es vor
allem in der medizin gab es weitere
anatomische untersuchen suche man mit
tieren eigentlich um menschliche körper
besser zu verstehen aber so logi als
wissenschaft erreicht ein stand mit hot
wheels war wovon man mit weiter
hinausgeht unser für sehr sehr lange
also bis zur firma gerne eignen sich
also es ist wirklich erstaunlich was er
da geschafft hat
und was wir hier vielleicht erwarten
würden in diesen psychologischen texten
ist dass wir lauter argumente bekommen
würden die so aussahen
also er würde immer feststellungen
satire äußern und dann sagen okay ich
meine begründe eine begründung für diese
feststellung der katzen haben kraulen
wieso haben sie kramen weil sie
raubtiere sind raubtiere brauchen waffen
um ihre beute zu fangen
zum beispiel könnte 12 deswegen haben
katzen auch waffen um ihre beute zu
fahren und so
so schreibt ja aber überhaupt nichts und
ein das ist also geheimnisses leicht
übertrieben aber ist eine frage die man
oft zu denen sie dann hat dieses werk er
aufstellt ist wieso es ist dass er in
seiner mit seinem werk zur technologie
in der analytik cup austria wie so
beschreibt er eine perfekte wissenschaft
und genau wie sie ausschauen soll welche
bedingungen die argumente und
erklärungen erfüllen soll
wieso macht er das und dann schreibt
buchstäblich hunderte und hunderte
seiten über wissenschaft zoologie ohne
überhaupt zu versuchen diese bedingungen
zu erfüllen das ist schon geheimnisvoll
eine idee wäre vielleicht dass diese
also erstens die pisten logische theorie
beschreibt ein ideal was man vielleicht
annehmen soll es werde dass das benzin
der wissenschaft werde dass man schöne
ketten von sie logistische argumente
geben würde und sie sagen einfach auf
der tafel schreiben könnte und sagen da
ist meine wissenschaftliche theologie
aber um das zu erreichen muss man sehr
viel sehr viele untersuchungen
machen und viele beobachtungen machen
und er ist immer noch in dieser phase wo
er diese werke scheint das wäre eine
idee eine andere idee ist dass das was
er in der historie als prostituierte
beschreibt er die perfekte art und weise
ist wissen darzustellen aber nicht
wissen zu erforschen und vielleicht geht
es in diesen werken mehr um das er uns
sagen will wie die forschung ausschaut
anstatt uns zeigen zu wollen was die
schlüsse sind die er am ende erreichen
könnte aber diese das ist eine
schwierige frage also wie man diese
logische werke mit der nötige pasteur
die oder in einklang bringt das ist
diskutabel
auf jeden fall gibt es mehrere werke
tiere normalerweise zählt man vier werke
zu den so typischen bergen nämlich der
partybus animalisch also über die teile
der tiere die historie anime um history
als krieg wir dass all das klingt also
das heißt wie geschichte der tieren aber
es solle heißt mehr so was wie berichte
berichte über tiere die generation hier
an im palladium also über fortpflanzung
oder erzeugung der tiere und dem motto
einem allem über die bewegung der tiere
andererseits könnte man vielleicht dazu
andere werke dazu zählen und es war die
werke die wir normalerweise als
psychologische werke beschreiben
natürlich der anima über die zelle dass
sein werk was manche von ihnen
wahrscheinlich schon in
lehrveranstaltungen gelesen wer hier hat
schon der anima gelesen aus neugier wohl
dass das das verbesserung
bedarf das werde ich der fakultät
weitergeben dass nur zehn prozent
unserer studierenden der anima gewesen
haben die okay dann sag ich das sagen
dass die an immer ein buch ist das sehr
bekannt ist und das fast von fast 1 plus
4 studieren normalerweise gelesen wird
das ist das werk was dort ließ seine
psychologie also liegt also studie über
die seele ist und erklärt was frühere
philosophen zu diesem thema gesagt
hatten
welche arten von selle es gibt usw
das könnte man irgendwie heiß als basis
ist eine so logi nehmen weil er in den
immer erklärt welche fähigkeiten man
pflanzen tieren und dann auf menschen zu
schreiben kann
dann gibt es übrigens auch ein paar
andere kürzere werke die heißen
normalerweise partner naturalien also
kleinere werke für naturphilosophie über
zum beispiel schlafen und träumen und
wahrnehmung usw
aber der nehmer ist wirklich grundlegend
für alles was er dann in der solo
gemacht und was er hier mag hat mit
dieser mit diesem thema zu tun dass ich
am anfang erwähnt habe nämlich art und
gattung also ganz oben wenn man sie
vielleicht doch etwas was ist was sind
die oberste garten die höchste gattungen
ich hab gesagt vielleicht denken aber
das sagt alles orte ließen nie das sagen
die story aber für alle sonst sind die
höchste gattungen diesem fall
wahrscheinlich pflanzen tiere und mensch
weil er diese zwei stufen zu sein
mit drei verschiedenen arten von seele
dann verbindet das sind die drei arten
von zellen also wenn man von unten
anfängt pflanzen sind lebewesen dessen
material lebewesen wobei das ist ein
bisschen jeder türen verwalten wie
mehrmals gesagt habe das wort so heißt
label lesen bedeutet aber tier also die
frage ob pflanzen pflanzen lebewesen
sind ist alles auf altgriechisch
festzustellen weil das klingt als ob man
fragen würde ist in pflanzen tiere also
sagen das ist schwierig aber hat er
sonst würde mindestens zu geben dass
pflanzen leben
also von daher sind sie lebewesen
unterhalb dieser ebene wenn man nur eine
pflanze seele hat zu sagen hat man nur
zwei haupt fähigkeiten nämlich die
fähigkeit sich zu ernähren und die
fähigkeit sich fortzupflanzen
wir haben bei pflanzen keine selbst
bewegung und wahrscheinlich denken sie
schon da stimmt doch nichts zum beispiel
können können sonnenblumen zur
entrichtung der sonne training so weiter
und so fort
aber wenn man das paradebeispiel wo der
satellit er denkt es bewegliche bewegung
um ein ziel
an zu schreiben also zum beispiel beute
nachzulaufen
und das können pflanzen nicht das ist
was er paradigmatisch und bewegung hier
vorstellt bei tiere wiederum haben wir
natürlich diese fähigkeit der bewegung
und sehr richtig und auch fällig bei
tieren sie können auch wahrnehmen
diese zwei fähigkeiten grund kann also
ganz grobe fähigkeiten hängen eng
zusammen weil bewegung bei einem tier
eigentlich normalerweise in der ersten
in erster linie dazu dient irgendeinem
wagen genommen das ziel nach zu
schreiben
das werde ich dann ja in kürze weiter
beschreiben aber die zwei sachen hängen
zusammen also ich sehe irgendwas und
bewege mich um das ding zu schnappen
zum beispiel eine katze die eine die
einem aussieht pragmatischer beispiel
dann ganz oben haben wir sehen die
vernunft besitzen das heißt dass sie
abstrakt denken können nicht nur
wahrnehmen sondern auch abstrakt denken
können zum beispiel sie das sind wesen
die philosophieren können
übrigens wenn es vielleicht mehr von
ihnen als die die an nummer gelesen
haben vielleicht haben viele von ihnen
etwas aus der ethiker nico markt eher
gelesen haben wer hat hier die kritik
geschrieben geld gestritten
wahrscheinlich keiner hat das war
aufregend oder
er ist hier wer hier hat die jetzt die
hektik wird man alles gelesen mindestens
teilweise ein bisschen besser geiles gut
da da erfahren wir dass das beste leben
und glücklich kai teutonia für menschen
darin besteht dass man vernunft gut
einsatz
und hier sieht man warum vernunft ist
das was unsere ziele kennzeichnet also
was uns als menschen haben und macht es
aus dass wir menschen sind und keine
tiere und wenn wir zum beispiel nur
verlust leben würden würden wir
buchstäblich tierisch neben das sagt ja
das sollten sie sogar es sagt am anfang
der attack dass das hedonistische leben
wo man nur verlust und vergnügen lebt
das ist ein leben was nicht von menschen
angemessen ist sondern für tiere hat
sogar für kühe
es ist das ist das leben eines kues
einer kuh nicht das leben eines menschen
also ganz grob haben wir diese
unterscheidung zwischen drei arten von
lebewesen und natürlich dann gibt es
weitere unterscheidungen innerhalb
diesen gattungen es gibt nur eine meint
ihr was vernünftig ist nämlich menschen
aber es gibt natürlich viele erhalten
und viele pflanzenarten also dass sie
sich irgendwie es sein das ist die dass
die die größte allgemeine beschreibung
der sphäre der lebewesen was wir dann in
den theologischen werken bekommen ist
eine sehr detaillierte beschreibungen
dieses wäre wenn sie sich den tieren
vor allem in der es torriani mariam das
ist das längste von denen das längste
von den vier werken die vorher genannt
habe
das ist sehr lang und also langweilig
ist nicht aber wenn man das aus schlägt
würde man nicht unbedingt den eindruck
haben dass man ein philosophisches werk
liest das sind viel mit berichte über
verschiedene tierarten wie ihre körper
gestaltet sind was sie essen legenden
darüber welche teile eines tierkörpers
medizinisch anwendbar sind und so weiter
und so fort und ist wirklich eine eine
einfach eine sammlung von informationen
ist sehr verschiedene halt so alles hier
hatten woran man überhaupt denken könnte
dessen systematische vielleicht von von
dem von der ansicht sind die andere
werke also dem motto anomalie an sehr
kurz ist eine erklärung wie viel
bewegung funktioniert ja wie gesagt ich
werde gleich mehr dazu sagen
und dann haben wir die generation der
anime um also über über ford langsam am
ende der vorlesung weg dazu über sagen
habe natürlich geht es hier darum zu
erkennen was passiert wenn tiere sich
erzeugen und hd party bassani man ihm
bis natürlich über die tierkinder und
hier sehr systematisch durch die
verschiedene arten von glieder zb meine
flügel und so weiter erklärt wie das
alles funktioniert und immer oder fast
immer hat man sehr stark den eindruck
dass alles obwohl er auch berichte von
anderen autoren oder augenzeugen
übernimmt oft sachen die offensichtliche
lächerlich sind also die legenden die
natürlich nicht stimmen können
er hat auch sehr
der theater ob beobachtungen die er in
diesen werken bands die er aus seinem
seiner eigenen erfahrung geholt hat zb
also sehr detaillierte beobachtungen
über die organen von verschiedenen
tieren und verschieden so weiter dann
weil bewegung so wichtig ist
in im bereich der tiere dort etwas dazu
sagen ich habe schon erwähnt dass
bewegung und wahrnehmung sehr eng
zusammengehören und das seien also seine
eigentliche gedanke hier ist dass tiere
wahrnehmung haben um ziele zu finden
ziele die sie dann anstreben können oder
wonach sie schreiben können nochmal
haupt beispiel wäre butter oder beute
natürlich sind manche tiere
fleischfresser man hier nicht das gilt
sogar für eine kur zum beispiel pussy
gras geht langsam dahin ist das gras
katzen sieht maus geht relativ zügig
kill team aus oder wahrscheinlich spielt
mit der maus und quält ihn aus für 40
minuten dann bringt sie die maus und das
team aus wenn sie lust hat
wahrscheinlich will sie erst gar nicht
lassen weil sie schon gegessen hat egal
also man sieht dass das diese es ist
nichts irgendwie zufällig dass diese
zwei fähigkeiten bei tieren immer wieder
vorkommen
hier ist ja das hat uns natürlich
bewusst dass tierarten sehr
unterschiedlich sind also die ersten
verschiedene futter zum beispiel
aber es gibt auch tiere die nicht alle
fünf sinnen besitzen zum beispiel nennt
er den maulwurf und fragt sich ob
maulwürfe blind sein sollen oder sind
sie nur zufällig bleiben weil sie unter
der erde wohnen dass es ihnen schwierig
aber es gibt auch andere wirklich
grenzverletzung zum beispiel und der
unterirdische oder seht ihr die fast die
pflanzen sind also können sich kaum
bewegen haben keine augen können mit
höheren aber haben ihre etats sind
anscheinend und er würde zugeben dass
wir manchmal grenzfälle finden wo wir
nicht sicher sind ob das pflanzen sind
oder tiere zum beispiel muscheln sind
muscheln tiere ja gerade noch aber die
sind basti pflanzen
aber das ist für ihn okay vielleicht
sogar für den von ihnen gewollt weil er
die idee mag dass wir hier sozusagen
einen leiter von lebewesen haben und
alle mögliche lebewesen kommen irgendwie
vor
also diese idee ist nicht auszugleichen
hat das wort erwähnt ist aber sehr
aristoteles und wird sehr oft haus
natürlich in der späteren
aristotelischen tradition gesagt 1 einen
punkt 1 kommt den er hier machen will
dass das tier
eine die die möglichkeit sich zu bewegen
haben oder die fähigkeit haben sich zu
begegnen und nicht nur bewegt zu werden
ich meine wenn ich zum beispiel das
mache ich habe gerade die stift in
bewegung gesetzt aber das heißt nicht
dass die gemeinde den stift kann kann
bewegen aber sich nicht bewegen
ja es kann bewegt sie kann bewegt werden
und alle körper können gewählt werden
aber nur die tierkörper können sich
bewegen
diese idee geht noch mal zurück zu
platon in mehreren dialog aber vor allem
in dem fall tross sagt plattform dass
die seele das prinzip der bewegung sei
das heißt die seele kann sich selbst in
bewegung setzen und kann darauf folgend
einen körper in bewegung setzen also
dass wenn endlich zum beispiel denke
dass das kann ich machen weil ich eine
serie haben die sich in bewegung setzen
kann und diese bewegung an meinem körper
irgendwie weitergeben kann in
verschiedenen weisen zum beispiel mit
wenden
aber für ihn wäre sogar denken bei der
vernehmung celle ein beispiel von sich
bewegen sagt intimus des denkens eine
kreisförmige bewegung ist was auch immer
das heißen soll
alles ist hier nur teilweise mit eines
mit platanenhain kam
einerseits will er zustimmen dass das
beseelte dass es was sich selbst in
bewegung setzen kann
und wenn man bewegungen sehr allgemein
versteht kann man das sogar bei pflanzen
sehen zb wachsen ist natürlich eine art
veränderung oder bewegung aber örtliche
bewegung
sehen wir nur bei tieren und da sieht
man dass das tier war das tier beseelt
ist fähig ist
diese bewegungen zu unternehmen
andererseits würde er auch sagen dass
tiere nur bedingt selbst bewegen sind
eben weil sie immer von einem ziel in
bewegung gesetzt werden zum beispiel die
katze sieht die maus dass die maus ist
das wahrgenommene ziel der bewegung der
katze und ohne die maus würde die katze
sich nicht bewegen
das heißt das ressort ließ die das tier
in einer weise sich selbst bewegt in
einer anderen weise bewegt wird wie die
stadt die maus bewegt die die katze als
was wir als finales finales ursache oder
and ursache oder ziel nennen könnten
könnten dass das ist das ziel der
bewegung der katze und nachdem die katze
dieses ziel wahrgenommen hat kann die
katze das ziel verfolgen und das ist
dann die selbst bewegung also wir können
sagen dass selbst bewegung bei tieren
auch immer ein beispiel von bewegt
werden bildet er würde auch sagen dass
begierde das ist was durch eine
wahrnehmung eines ziels entsteht also
dass durch die ganze geschichte werde so
was
wir haben ein ziel war es ein tier haben
wollen könnte und das verursacht in den
tier begierde mit jede verursacht
bewegung in richtung ziel
und das ist irgendwie alles ziemlich man
kennt jetzt denken okay das irgendwie
offensichtlich aber dass auch eine
psychologische analyse von vielen vielen
tierhandlungen also das ist dass es
irgendwie paradigmatisch was ein tier
war sein tier ausmacht das kann alles
das kann eine pflanze nichts weil die
pflanze wahrnehmung nicht besetzt weil
du brauchst wahrnehmung damit das tier
das ziel
zuerst als müll als ziel erfassen kann
ohne der uni wahrnehmung hat keine
begierde ohne begierde keine bewegung
das mit
würde man vielleicht denken aber er
würde sagen dass es gibt die frage ob
überhaupt ob es überhaupt vorkommen kann
dass irgendwas bewegungen verursachen
kann ohne bewegt zu werden oder es ist
immer so dass man jedem dass bewegung
entsteht oder veränderung vielleicht
allgemeine gesagt dass veränderungen
immer entsteht dadurch dass man mit
einem anderen objekt engagiert und dass
das objekt mich bewegt die meisten
derzeit das funktionieren wir genau wie
tiere also werden in bewegung gesetzt
und zwar von anderen von wahrgenommen
wenn es wirklich der fall ist dass wir
unbewegt uns unbewegt bewegen können
dann wäre dann nur weil wir zum beispiel
ich sitze eine stunde lang und dann
entscheide mich auf zu stehen
das schaut so aus also ich unbewegt
nicht bewege aber als ort ließ hahn
mindestens in der physik argumentiert er
dass nur gott sich unbewegt bewegen kann
oder dass nur gott unbe weltbewegung
verursachen kann bei gott sich auch
niedlich bewegt natürlich aber gott ist
an das prinzip der bewegung der ganzen
welt und setzt die welt in bewegung ohne
bewegt zu sein deswegen haben sie
wahrscheinlich alle gehört dass gott das
unglück der unbewegte beweger ist dies
das ist genau das das ist der
hintergrund dieser aussage tiere sind
bewegte beweger wir auch gott ist ein
unbewegter bewege ob das plausibel ist
natürlich eine interessante frage ein ob
es plausibles dass menschen und sogar
tiere sich nicht unterkriegen
von später in der tradition wo es ab der
spätantike und dann vor allem in der im
mittelalter haben wir jetzt ja auch auf
die idee dass freie fälle genau das
erste was unbewegte bewegung ermöglicht
also freiheits nach des klassischen
auffassung oder wissens nach einer
ausgelassenen auffassung ist genau die
fähigkeit bewegungen zu starten ohne
bewegt zu sein
weil deswegen das ist man casal nicht
terminiert aber andere aber die die
treue hat das tut erika sagen nein nein
das stimmt doch nicht weil das ziel uns
in bewegung setzt sogar beim denken
haben wir das ziel des denkens okay und
das bringt uns zu einer allgemeinen
frage die für hat das model dieses tier
philosophie ist sehr wichtig ist nämlich
theologie noch ein griechisches wort das
hat mit dem griechischen worte telos
kennt oder zweck oder ziel zu tun so
viel technologie ist das phänomen wo
irgendwie sind zwecke oder ziele dann
involviert das ist er theologie und ich
glaube wenn man nur eine wenn man nur
eine us-aktion teilweise löschen
hier verlor sie benennen würde die
wirklich belohnt und wichtig auch
geschichtlich wichtig ist dann dass die
idee dass tiere teleologische lesen sind
das heißt dass sie zwar haben und dass
sie sozusagen so gebaut sind um ihre
zwecke zu erfüllen
und man sieht sofort wie gut dass sich
zum beispiel mit einem christlichen mit
einer christlichen terry verbünden
könnte also die idee werde
was wäre ein gutes weiß dass gott die
welt geschaffen hat tiere und ihre tiere
biotechnologisch gestalten gestaltet
sind zum beispiel katzen haben diese
super kran womit sie beute fangen können
das ist nicht so gut für die beute
natürlich aber die beute ist auch super
schnell also neu sie haben diese super
worden damit sie dann angreifen die
katzen wahrnehmen können sie können
davon entlaufen übrigens vielleicht
hätte ich das auch gesagt dass wir sind
nicht also bewegung immer nur richtung
beute erst bewegung kann auch zum
beispiel weg von einem jagenden tieres
sein aber ich selbst da da haben wir mit
1 wahrgenommen das ziel zu tun nämlich
sicherheit also ein ein ort ohne katz
und dann läuft die man den ausweg und
wenn man tiere anschaut ist natürlich
sehr sehr auffällig wie gut jeder
gestaltet sind um ihre ziele zu
erreichen lieblingsbeispiel von mir sind
natürlich die giraffen die den langen
haus haben damit sie die hohe blätter
erreichen können
ich hab gerade gelernt dass graphen sie
haben diese so ein muster wo sie dunkle
plakat die haut haben s und s ich habe
gerade gelernt sagt er ich dachte immer
das hat nur mitteilungen zu tun und es
hat sogar mitteilungen zu tun und
vielleicht auch an können sie sich
gegenseitig identifizieren weil jede
gerade eine bestimmte ein bestimmtes
muster hat aber anscheinend gibt es auch
blutgefäße und diesen flecken und dass
sie dunkel sind erlaubt dass das blut in
diesen gefäßen dann kühler bleibt es ist
dann diesen so gebaut
heute gestaltet in großer hitze sowie
überleben unter anderem durch diesen
hautflecken ein anderes beispiel was ich
erst dieses jahr gelernt haben das hat
mich echt verblüfft wenn sie daran
denken es gibt sehr sehr sehr viele
tierarten die oben dunkles sind und
unten hält ja und das ist auch
revolutionsführer das ist zweckmäßig der
fall zb das beste beispiel ist ein
fischer sind unten hell und dunkel weil
wenn ein fisch fressende / unter dem
fisch ist schaut der jäger hoch und hoch
ist alles hell von der sonne
deswegen wirst du von unten hell sein
weil dafür dann wirst du gut getarnt
aber oben wirst du dunkel ist ein bald
wieder gut getan fest weil kunden ist
dunkel
genial oder verscherzt hatte recht und
als ob dies war vielleicht von dieser
tatsächlich nicht bewusst aber war sehr
sehr gut bewusst dass tiere all diese
definierte eigenschaften besitzen die
erlauben dass die dass die tiere ihre
zwecke erfüllen können und er würde
sagen und das solo gi unter anderem dazu
dient uns erklärungen zu liefern
wieso die tiere so gebaut sind mit
hinblick auf diese ziele zb das display
bisher gesagt katzen haben kann wieso
haben sie krank
damit sie beute fangen können und das
wäre für ihn eine ein wissenschaftliches
argument die und glaube die erklärung
hier die seine erklärung die mit einem
ziel zu tun hat und nichts zum beispiel
organe oder was wir vielleicht wirkte
sachen nennen können vergleichen sie
zwei verschiedene erklärungen für die
krallen eines in einer katze erste
erklärung die krallen sind da und beute
zu fangen zweite erklärung
es gibt eine ist sehr kompliziert ein
sehr kompliziertes verfahren in der mama
katz wenn die katze im bauch der mama
katze entwickelt da bildet er erdiges
mit ready die material auf und das wird
durch irgendwelche gefäße geschickt und
am ende entstehen kann
ja also das ist eine rein physische
erklärungen die nichts mit viel zu tun
hat ähnlicher weise könnte man eine
anderes beispiel nehmen zb ich gehe zur
tür
wieso mache ich das wie es wieso hat es
allerdings in zur tour gegangen eine
erklärung weil wir hier vorhaben und er
will das zimmer verlassen er war das
erst der erste das zu merken und hat
nicht einmal den studierenden gesagt
dieses projekt das die das verbrannt
hier haben erst einfach davon gelaufen
so ein tag okay das war der grund
könnten personen
das wäre eine gute erklärung dass er
dass es eine final ursache ende ursache
zwerg ursache aber es gibt auch andere
ursachen dafür zb seine zelle hat ihn in
bewegung gesetzt oder seine muskeln
haben ausgedient und wo sagen man muss
gut tun wenn man geht das hat ermöglicht
dass er heraus gegangen ist und für all
das sind all diese erklärungen gute
erklärungen und auch wissenschaftliche
wärmen er würde nicht sagen dass der
biologe oder so locke versuchen soll und
nur sachen oder zwei ursachen aus der
wissenschaft zu verbannen und alles nur
durch zusagen die regeln der physik zu
machen er würde sagen nein
tiere sind hier teleologische wesen sind
so gebaut dass sie ihre zwecke verfolgen
können und erfüllen können und man ohne
diese zwecke zu verstehen wirst du nie
verstehen wieso tiere soßen wie sie sind
das ist übrigens alles ohne dass er auf
zb einen göttlichen schöpfer oder
gestalten
dann sei er wenn es sowas gar nichts
nun scheint es ist relativ
sogar deutlich dass er sowas nicht
annimmt also es gibt keinen schöpfer der
alles gebaut hat damit die tiere
zweckmäßig gewesen sind ich habe immer
wieder gesagt sie sind zweckmäßig gebaut
oder gestaltet oder so aber es gibt
keinen bauer es gibt keinen gestalter
hier ist dass das ist wird ein
deutlicher unterschied zwischen ihm und
platin bei 1 teams ein dialog den ich
mehrmals erwähnt habe vor allem das der
woche lernen wir dass es einen so
genannten göttlichen handwerker gibt ein
die amigos der die ganze welt bunt auch
die frischen die tiere und auch unsere
körper baut und gestaltet als nur ihr
habt lasst ihr sollt gesagt dass alles
eine nachahmung der form des lebewesens
in der in dem ideenreich und was der dem
mythos macht diese göttliche handwerker
nach platon ist genau das ist zu denken
okay wie kann ich das möglich die
ideenwelt hier in der materiellen welt
realisiert
und da gibt es platin beispiele wie also
das berühmte beispiel aus dem team aus
ist unser schädel und schädel ist so
dick wie er ist weil wenn er dicker wäre
hätten wir mehr schutz aber und mehr so
gehirn werde kleiner und dann werden wir
dumme aber wenn der schädel dünner werde
damit werde ein größeres gehirn hatten
haben könnten dann würden wir zu wenig
sicherheit haben zu wenig schutz und
dieses die das ab und soll schädel ist
ein kompromiss zwischen schutz und
intelligenz und würde von dem handwerker
ausgesucht damit es bestmöglich
realisiert wird wenn bei hat es soll das
würde ähnliches sagen oder könnte
ähnliches sagen über den schädel
er würde aber keinen handwerker benennen
er würde einfach sagen es ist einfach in
der natur der in der menschlichen natur
vorgegeben dass wir einen solchen
schädel haben und natürlich ist das
genau perfekt und zweckmäßig weil es so
ist die natur also die natur es fing an
sich theologisch hier wendet er sich
gegen betis war schon gesehen lässt ihn
gesehen dass empathie ist diese theorie
hatte
dass materie zusammenkommt glieder
bildet glieder kommen zusammen zufällig
beliebig und wenn es passt kann die
diese zusammensetzungen von gliedern
sich fortpflanzen und daraus entstehen
die tierarten und wir haben schon
gesehen heute gesehen dass es dass es in
einer weise gegen das lotterielos oder
aber sie werde dagegen weil die batterie
ist natürlich will dass die taten ewig
sind es gibt vielleicht sogar eine 1
einem wichtigeren kommt hier nämlich
dass mps
die tiere hatten erklärt ohne theorie
technologie einzusetzen weil es nur eine
beliebige ein beliebiges zusammenkommen
diese gliedern die zufällig
weiterexistieren können oder sich
fortpflanzen können und alles ist
dagegen noch nie wollte einen auszug aus
seiner physik vorlesen wo er das
bespricht haben den text habe ich mit
dem händler auf lsf dann dabei die
hierarchie ist versiegt buch zwei
kapitel 18 sie relativ lang anzugeben
ist also zuvörderst liefern die native
die übersetzungen aus dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert also das wird jetzt sehr
gelegen sein
abwechslungsreich ok anzugeben also zu
fördern sie fern die natur sie den ende
ursachen gehört also diese zweck
ursachen
sodann zu sprechen über das notwendige
wie es sich bei dem natürlichen verhält
es fragt sich aber was hindert dass die
natur nicht eines zweckes wegen tätig
sei oder weil es besser ist sondern wie
wenn der himmel regnet nicht damit dass
getreide wächst sondern haus
notwendigkeit das ausgeschiedene nämlich
muss gefühlen und das gefrorene wasser
geworden herabfallen das aber wenn dies
geschieht das gewächs trifft sich so
neben bei gleicher weise auch wenn
jemandem verdirbt das getreide in der
tenne so regnete es nicht deshalb damit
es bei derbe sondern dies traf sich
nebenbei daher die frage etwas handelt
das nicht ebenso die teile sich
verhalten in der natur das zum beispiel
die zähne aus notwendigkeit wachsen die
fordern scharf geeignet auseinander sie
teilen die backenzähne breit und tüchtig
zu sakralen die speise nicht deswegen
nämlich seien sie entstanden sondern
dies habe sich so zugetragen
ich war gestern leider beim zahnarzt und
ich habe in meinem zahnarzt über diese
passage erzählt
und ich habe auch er sich im stuhl war
habe ich diese vorlesung vor kombiniert
als abwechslung oder als ablenkung von
der den nicht ganz angenehmen verfahren
was da stattgefunden hat also dass es
viel besser also diese fassung der
vorlesung ist viel angenehmer zu geben
erklärt aktien gleicher weise auch bei
den anderen teilen in welchen scheint
stattzufinden das weswegen wo nun alles
sich traf wie wenn es zu einem zweck
entstanden werde da war gerettet was von
ungefähr siehst du passen zusammen
gefunden hatte was ich aber nicht so
drauf das ging unter und geht unter wie
im paddock ließ sagt von dem chor
geschlecht mitmenschen antlitz es ist
ein eingestallt was nicht überleben
konnte war das war nicht so sagt
zusammenkommen zusammenkommen was nicht
passend war dieses nun ist es wenn was
man einwenden könnte und vielleicht noch
gerade dass dergleichen
es kann sich aber dies nicht auf diese
weise verhalten dandys und alles was von
der natur ist geschieht eben entweder so
oder so meiste von dem hab von dem haben
was aus zufall und von ungefähr ist
nichts
ok also der punkt ist es gibt diese
theorien die wir bei den vorzug vatikan
und vor allem bei im paddock ließen dass
das natürliche und ein paradebeispiel
tierkörper weil wir ich immer wieder
sage jetzt ihr körper sind das beispiel
schlechthin für gut gestalten in natur
ja den punkt habe ich schon am anfang
der vorherigen vorlesungen gemacht und
manche wollten als das resultat des
zufalls erklären ein per dekret zum
beispiel alles gesagt nein das stimmt
nicht
du kannst nicht diese regelmäßigkeit die
wir in der natur ist durch zufall
erklären weil das zufällige
ist das nicht das was immer so ist oder
fast immer so wie er hier sagt die
etikette die dies und alles was von
natur es geschieht eben entweder so oder
so meisten hospital das heißt was fast
immer passiert oder immer passiert das
ist das natürliche und das zufällige ist
immer eine ausnahme hat er hat der
größere zusammenhang her ist dass er
eine ganze theorie über zufälligkeit hat
wo er sagt dass das zufällige wenn wir
was zufällig nennen oder wenn wir das
wenn wir irgendwas glück oder glücksfall
nennen dass es immer ein fall wo
irgendetwas geschieht was man vielleicht
beabsichtigen könnte aber nicht beachtet
hat ein beispiel raum was er erwähnt ist
dass man vielleicht vielleicht will man
jemanden vielleicht schuldet mir jemand
geld und ich gehe zum markt nur
einzukaufen und behaltet alt da steht er
also ich kann mein geld zurück kriegen
aber das wollte ich nicht
das ist nur ein glücksfall weil das ist
ein glücksfall weil ich es beabsichtigen
könnte habe ich aber nicht und da daran
sieht man dass glücksfälle immer eine
ausnahme sind die sind als ob gewollt
aber nicht gewollt
wenn natürlich die die natürliche
eigenschaften der tieren zb sind
wirklich gewollt nicht von jemandem
gewollt aber in der natur gewollt sie
sind ziele oder sie sind zweckmäßige um
ziele zu erreichen zb die kahlen der
katze oder was auch immer oder schädel
alle tiere alle
regelmäßige eigenschaften der tiere sind
gewollt im sinne von zweckmäßig aber wie
gesagt ohne einen göttlichen gestalt
anzunehmen
ok dann letztes thema was ich erwähnen
wollte ist fortpflanzung und natürlich
hängt das damit zusammen was ich gerade
gesagt habe fortpflanzung ist auch ein
sehr gutes beispiel vielleicht das
beispiel von theologie weil wir hier
sehen dass tierkörper diese zweckmäßige
körper irgendwie produziert werden und
alles hat alles wirklich sehr
interessiert wie das stattfinden der
versucht schwangere tiere sie zieren zu
sehen wie die harburg die organe
fortpflanzungsorgane in tieren
funktionieren usw hat sehr sehr viel
dazu zu sagen aber ohne all diese
details zu besprechen wollte ich nur ein
paar hauptthemen erwähnen
erstens und das ist sehr berechtigt wir
haben schon gewarnt dass sie das
wahrscheinlich nicht mögen werden
sollten sie auch nicht
er behauptet dass der die form die eine
tierhaut hausmacht vorwiegend von dem
wasser kommt die mutter tier oder mensch
liefert eigentlich die materie für diese
form und wenn sie ein bisschen anders
kennen dann wissen sie dass substanzen
hausform und materie
dann bestehen also es gibt immer eine
potenzial i tät die in der materie
dann setzt zusammen und dann gibt es die
form die diesen potentially tät in
erfüllung bringt und grob gesagt kann
man sagen dass in seiner theorie der
biologie oder fortpflanzung dass es dass
die mutter dafür zuständiges die materie
vorzubereiten dann kommt die form durch
den samen des vaters
und der samen kocht die materie das blut
in dem die in der gebärmutter und dann
entsteht langsam ein tier durch
bewegungen die das die der örtliche
samen fortgesetzt hat andererseits hat
ja hier hatte er in offensichtliches
problem dass tiere eigenschaften von der
mutter auch werden können
und wenn die mutter nur bloße materie
vorbereitet kann man das nicht erklären
deswegen ist es eigentlich viel
komplizierter als man oft in der
literatur liest mutter materie vater
form sagt jetzt eigentlich viel
komplizierter ist als wenn man
tatsächlich an die generation anomalie
um liest
da könnte man mehr dazu erst sein aber
die eigentliche idee ist dass die
materie in einer bestimmten mutter auch
bestimmte eigenschaften hat sozusagen
contest konsistenz oder vielleicht an
bestimmte tsunamis potentially täten um
irgendwelche eigenschaften zu
realisieren also zurück zu den pferden
des braun weißes pferd noch mal die
tatsache dass eine weiße mutter eine
weiße wert mutter eineinhalb weißes
kennt produziert liegt darin dass die
potentially tät weißes fell zu haben in
der materie schon vorhanden ist wenn man
das wirklich durch denkt sieht man dass
es ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
richtiges zu sagen dass die form durch
den vater nur durch den vater kommt für
ihre eigenschaften sind wegen der mutter
da in den kennt trotzdem wahrscheinlich
immer aktienanteile eigenschaften also
es ist führt uns zurück zu der antwort
die ich zu ihnen gegeben habe
dann wollte ich auch erwähnen weil das
in späteren vorlesungen besprechen werde
das alles zugibt dass tiere spontan
entstehen können zum beispiel sehen wir
das in ausschalten fleisch fliegen oder
hürmer entstehen können
und das ist für ihn einfach eine
offensichtliche beobachtung die man
nicht bestreiten kann viel viel viel
viel später hat man natürlich entdeckt
dass das alles nicht stimmt
aber sie bei der schotte ließ und für
viele jahrhunderte danach ist man davon
ausgegangen dass tiere spontan entstehen
können das ist natürlich für ihn ein
riesenproblem
weil sie seine ganze so logi nimmt anna
nimmt das tier hatten durch diese
regelmäßige fortpflanzung entstehen oder
bestehen also hört man das hat es noch
nie so einen zum begeistert war über
spontane entstehung der tieren das für
ihn eher ein problem was er erklären
muss und das macht ja dadurch dass er
versucht haben zu behaupten dass das
spontane erzeugung eines die richmond
spontane erzeugen eines tieres sind es
ist eigentlich analog zu den natürlichen
fortpflanzung
wir haben irgendwelche materie zum
beispiel vertraut verfaultes fleisch
dann haben wir eine wirkung sache zum
beispiel wärme von der sonne und die
wärme von der sonne spielt die rolle des
vaters das verhalten bleibt spielt die
rolle der mutter
die kommen zusammen und dann entsteht
ein tier aber ein einfaches tier würmer
fliegen keine menschen oder werde also
ist nicht also wir ausschlagen sollte
plötzlich ein pferd
und dann verläuft nein nur diese miese
bescheidene tierarten können spontan
erzeugt werden die wir später sehen
werden würde das kontrovers diese ganze
tiere die ok und letzter punkt haben wir
bei all das ließ tierethik kurze antwort
nein es gibt keine tierethik bayer das
ist so weit wie ich weiß gibt es keine
einzige passage wo er sich zur moralisch
vertretbare behandlung der tiere äußert
und das ist irgendwie leicht zu erklären
wenn man seine ethische und politische
werke anschaut und sieht woher unsere
pflichte entstehen
wir haben pflicht die zum beispiel zu
unseren freunden durch die freundschaft
beim klicken die entstehen durch
konzerte unsere fähigkeit vernunft
einzusetzen
angeblich so gut von und einzusetzen wie
möglich hier kann ich das nicht machen
deswegen haben sie keine pflicht sie
haben keine beziehung kritisiert
beziehung zu uns sie sind auch keinen
keine mitglieder unserer politischen
gesellschaft also all die quellen der
realität zu sein oder oder der ethischen
pflicht die bayer das anerkennt werden
schließen tiere haus und deswegen sind
hier der für ihn nur sehr sehr
interessante und raffinierte beispiele
von der tatsache dass die natur
teleologische existiert oder dass die
natur theologischen gebaut ist also erst
super begeistert wenn es um tiere geht
obwohl er gar nichts zur ethischen frage
dann zu sagen hat was natürlich
interessant ist und wir werden in der
kommenden in den kommenden wochen sehen
dass das eigentlich eine ausnahme
also erst zwei sogar zweifach eine
ausnahme er ist ein ausnahmefall weil er
sich so sehr für biologie interessiert
also tiere als gegenstand der
wissenschaft kommt vielmehr bei hatte
ließ vor als bei was jedem anderen
antiken philosophie auch in anderen
kulturen also es wirklich eine ausnahme
aber er ist auch eine ausnahme weil er
nicht kein versuch gemacht hat zu
erklären wie tiere uns moralisch bezogen
sind
das ist für ihn einfach nicht so
relevant so ich glaube haben jetzt ein
paar minuten noch jemand fragen standen
ja nur was man hessen soll